Speaker 1: More than 100 Trump officials, former
Trump officials are now backing Ron DeSantis for
president. But if you think it matters, MAGA does
not care. Disclaimer This is a Fox News report.
It appears as though they are properly sourcing
this, but it is a Fox News report, an interesting
detail in its own right. The headline Over 100
former Trump administration officials backed
DeSantis for president, quote, a proven winner.
The officials have formed a coalition called
the eight year Alliance. Jung DeSantis is a viable
two term candidate. Exclusive Fox News has learned
that more than 100 former Trump administration
officials have formed a growing coalition backing
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis to be their nominee,
according to multiple sources within the group.
The eight year Alliance says the Santos is a
proven winner, a contender with a depth of policy
proven by what he's done at the state level and a
leader who does what he says. All of those seem to
be lies. I don't think anything there is true. The
primary motivation of the group, sources say, is
to promote a candidate they feel would be a viable
contender for two presidential terms, something
they see in DeSantis. They also want to prevent
former President Donald Trump, quote, immediately
becoming a lame duck president should he win back
the White House. Considering the polarizing effect
his persona has had on American politics, now
they're using the wrong word. They're using the
wrong effect. It says the polarizing affect. I
believe that that is incorrect. But we'll get
into grammar more today in the in the voicemail
segment. So what's fascinating about this is that
MAGA voters do not care. And we've talked more
about becoming a victim of the very monster you
created. That's something we've talked about
before. The monster that is MAGA does not care
that we don't know who's in this group, but oh,
John Bolton doesn't like Trump anymore. William
Barr doesn't think Trump is the right person to
lead the Republican Party. We don't care. Those
were losers that Trump had to fire. And then
when you say to them, well, why did Trump hire
them in the first place, I thought he was great at
hiring. Oh, forget about that. Forget about that.
So, you know, again, we look at the polling,
Trump continuing to climb. Last week,
he breached 55% support. He continues to climb.
He is now beyond 56% support. We mentioned last
week that the Santos dropped below 20% for the
first time. And I don't even know how long a very,
very long time this may even be. When was the
scent? DeSantis was last below 20 in October,
and DeSantis is again below 20. And by the end of
the week, he may be below 19. The MAGA voters do
not care about what Republican officials who
once worked for Trump have to say they are
for Trump. We are going to actually this Friday
in the Friday feedback or the feedback segment,
as it may be called, we're going to
see cultists who straight up say,
I will not vote for anyone else. It's Trump or
nothing. That is it. So this is not likely to be
a group of former Trump officials that has much,
if any, impact on the primary. Just look at the
polling. It is a blowout for Trump. He it's
his to lose is where I would leave it. Hey,
quick reminder, Monday, Memorial Day, there will
be no show. We are taking off the federal holiday,
but there will be a one day membership special,
the likes of which you have never seen before.
There are not many such examples that
I can tell you. Get on my newsletter a
David Pacman dot com and then Monday morning
you'll get a beautiful email telling you how
to avail yourself of this historic membership
discount. Quick break. Much, much more today.